so what would happen if the wraith and
the goal ruled went to war
who would win
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so a couple of days ago matt dropped a
video on the channel telling you how if
the wraith and the gold went to war the
wraith would win
but now i'm here to tell you what would
really happen and now the gold would
really be victorious in this conflict
the only way this conflict could really
happen is if the gold world found
atlantis before humanity did so before
the towers sent their expedition to the
atlantic city the gold would somehow
found it and arrived there first
so
first of all i'm going to sort of
compare and contrast the two warring
factions here and we have to set the
scene a little bit so first of all you
have to remember that the wraith are
actually asleep when the towery arrived
at atlantis and we could assume they
probably would be again now i am going
to concede straight away that in a
full-out battle all of the wraith
against all the gold i think the wraith
would win quite quickly at the end of
the day the wraith battled against the
atlanteans the people that turned into
the ancients and were victorious they
pushed the atlanteans out of the pegasus
galaxy
they did that not through technology but
through sheer numbers
they used stolen zpm's to create massive
cloning factories and they simply
outnumbered the atlanteans pushing them
back to atlantis and eventually pushing
them out of the galaxy altogether
actually think in a straight up conflict
between the gold and a wraith the wraith
would do the same again and they would
just outnumber the gold and eventually
win
but in this scenario the gold world have
found the atlantis city and the wraith
are currently asleep so when the wraith
begin to wake up the main conflict is
going to be fought between the jaffa and
the drones now the drones are hybrid
between the iritis bug and humans and
they are considered to be a little bit
unimaginative in their fighting but they
do also have a psychic link with the
wraith themselves and that is an
advantage also similarly to the jaffra
in fact the wraith drones do heal and
are very very hard to kill
i feel that the jaffa are
loyal in that they believe the golden
gods the wraith drones are loyal because
they're grown and designed to be
but i actually think the jaffa in
one-on-one combat army against army
would probably be victorious assuming
equal numbers etc simply because the
rafe drones are unimaginative they're
not very battle hardened they're not
very tactical whereas the jaffa will
adapt tactics to fight this enemy i
should also say that the gold are kind
of like techno cuckoos they are very
good at absorbing other people's
technology and they are not stupid we
saw several times during sg1 that the
the gold are actually very intelligent
and that through genetic memory they
absorb each other's intelligence as well
so they're technologically very capable
if they got to the atlantis base i think
they would acquire technologies and use
the city far quicker and probably far
better than the towering ever did
i think in that respect that they would
probably develop new technologies to
fight the wraith again far quicker than
we ever did
so
from that respect i think the goldwool's
ability to
basically steal other people's
technology and absorb it into their own
would be a massive advantage early on in
this conflict
another possibility of course is that
the gold world could infect a wraith
themselves i wonder if a goal symbiote
getting into a wraith
and then being able to absorb their
intelligence and their information into
the gold collective would again give the
gold another advantage
if they were able to
capture a good number of wraith
and then through the gold symbiote
learn about their enemy far quicker than
the tower ever could then again that
would give them a massive advantage in
the coming war
[Music]
ship on ship
in this um scenario
basically the gold world will have
arrived at the city through a gate so
they would not have any of their big
capital ships so at least initially um
the gold would have to use the puddle
jumpers the same as a tower he did but
if they were able to get some attacks
and other vessels
the atlantis base i don't know how that
would happen what would the fight
between the hive ships and the attacks
look like
well to be honest
the standard hive ship in the hatak i
think that they would need two or three
attacks to attack each hive shift the
hive ships are big they are well armed
if they had a super hive ship a hive
ship powered by zpm's
well we already know that the hive ship
that um took on the deadlifts
absolutely wiped the floor with it
direct hit damage
minimal
ready missiles we're gonna throw
everything we have at this guy sir i'm
reading a massive energy buildup
race for impact
down
i don't think any attack would stand
even a fleet of attacks would stand
against that vessel for very long but
all being standard
i think that you would need two or three
attacks for each hive ship but there
aren't many hive ships so again if there
was a full fleet of say system lord
vessels
and the limited number of hive ships we
know to exist it could be a fair battle
but
the hataks would have to outnumber the
hive ships at least two or three to one
for me another possibility and actually
for me a more likely possibility is what
if anubis found the atlantis city
as he had some of the knowledge from the
ancients it is most logical that he
would be the one to find the city
[Applause]
he also would have access to a lot of
ancient knowledge and memory and he
would know again how to take advantage
of the city far quicker even quicker
than any other gold could
[Music]
me
[Music]
if this was the case and it was anubis
that got to atlantis first and anubis
was then able to use this technology and
build a fleet and the pegasus galaxy i
actually think if the wraith didn't wake
up quickly anubis would potentially
destroy them before they even had a
chance to start a battle
i actually think anubis was one of the
most terrifying and well-rounded
villains in all of stargate if he had
arrived at the atlantis colony first
while the way through sleep i don't
think the wraith would be in that chance
i think he probably would have took them
out before the fight even started
because in any conflict between the
wraith and the gold world
you can argue that the wraith were able
to defeat humanity and were able to beat
the atlanteans but in fighting the gold
they're fighting a completely different
kettle of fish the gold world are
ruthless now they have their weaknesses
their hubris is a massive weakness they
are seriously overconfident but when
they come face to face with a new enemy
they can be completely vicious
they would not hesitate like the taori
did they would not consider or try to
find any peaceful resolutions this
conflict they would go all out
immediately
and they would slaughter the wraith with
any opportunity and any weapon that they
could find for me in a toe-to-toe fight
between the wraith and the gold yeah
okay the gold world would lose but i
don't think the gold world would go in a
toe to toe fight with the wraith i think
they would use every trick in the book
and in that case in a dirty conflict and
maybe even a guerrilla conflict fought
from the atlantis base
i think the gold world would absolutely
wipe the floor with the wraith but i
would love to know what you think get in
the comments and tell us exactly who
would win between the wraith and the
gold also
check matthew's video out and leave a
comment on there too does he make any
good points or is he just talking
rubbish as usual
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification and if you want to become a
fully fled sidetracker please hit that
join button as always guys please stay
safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you